[Applaudissements]
sur le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues avec le réchauffement
climatique la question de l'eau est de
plus en plus préoccupante l'été 2022
marquée par une sécheresse record et
généralisée à nattes l'eau est
indispensable à une multitude
d'activités comme elle est indispensable
aux grandes équilibres des milieux
naturels notre pays c'est doté d'une
législation qui vise en équilibre entre
les différents usages de l'eau il s'agit
de répondre à nos besoins tout en
préservant la ressource à travers toute
une série d'outils un de ces outils est
le débit réservé la loi interdit de
prélever dans un cours d'eau si cela
conduit à réduire son débit en dessous
d'un certain seuil et ce pour préserver
la faune et la flore aquatique si le
principe est vertueux j'attire votre
attention sur ces difficultés
d'application et les dérivent auxquelles
nous assistons saisis par des
associations de protection de
l'environnement le juge administratif
est amené à fixer les débits réservés
bien au-dessus de se décider par des
préfectures dans les pionniers
orientales des prises d'eau sur le
fleuve Coty la tête qui servent à
alimenter les canaux d'irrigation aux
ancestraux faisant vivre une agriculture
maraîchère familiale sont condamnés à
être inopérantes et par décision du juge
qui a estimé que les calculs des
services de la préfecture pourtant très
compétents étaient erronés se basant sur
d'anciennes études de volume prélevable
par ailleurs contestées le juge fait une
application maximale des textes en
s'écartant de l'objectif d'équilibre
entre les différents usages de l'eau au
risque de condamner les activités
maraîchères locales et de faire
disparaître le système des canaux qui
contribue pourtant à la biodiversité
locale ailleurs à Sallanches en
Haute-Savoie cette même interprétation
maximaliste du débit réservé pour y
conduire à la destruction du lieu
central hydroélectrique neuve madame la
ministre ma question est simple
envisagez-vous de modifier les modalités
d'appréciation du débit réservé pour
éviter de décimer les agriculteurs en
les empêchant d'accéder à l'eau